larry elder radio host of the larry
elder show your thoughts on don lemon
uh it's pretty pathetic but all he's
doing is following joe biden's lead
let's remember the president referred to
kyle rittenhouse as a white supremacist
and so that's the line karen bass is a
black member of the house she's from
california and she referred to the
weapon that kyle rittenhouse had the
ar-15 as an automatic weapon and
remember the media reported very widely
that uh kyle rittenhouse uh uh uh that
uh jacob blake that sparked all of this
was unarmed that's the black man who was
shot in the back
uh in kenosha that sparked all these uh
uh protests and riots and looting
he was of course not unarmed he admitted
that he was not unarmed he admitted he
dropped the gun
dropped the knife rather he picked it up
and that he wasn't thinking clearly when
he did it and also opposed the riots
that took place in kenosha so after he
got shot
and had some reflection he's been one of
the more sensible people in this whole
drama speaking of which uh how did this
become a referendum jesse on race
relations a written house is white the
three people that were shot two of whom
were shot fatally are white the judge is
white from what i can tell all the
prosecution team is white the defense
team is white but the only two black
people uh in the courthouse are the uh
the black juror and al sharpton how'd
this thing become a referendum on race
relations here's why it did because a a
white teenager interfered with a racial
riot that's why you can't interfere with
mob justice you're supposed to lay back
and watch the city burn so obviously you
have to be a racist if you're going to
try to protect
businesses from being torched by black
lives matter activists it's interesting
larry that the left like lemon has to
resort to a hypothetical well what if
kyle rittenhouse was black well he's not
black they just deal with the facts of
the case the facts in the case aren't
good for the left um because they want
this kid cooked so they have to just
create like a fake story in order to
justify their argument
well that's right he's been likened to
bull connor that's the democrat southern
sheriff that uh sicked uh water hoses
and dogs on civil rights workers uh
these people were not civil rights
workers they were looters they were
rioters they were protests and that's
why kyle rittenhouse went there uh so
the analogy is completely ridiculous uh
all these guys have is a race card uh
and and a black democrat activist has
argued that
employers ought to allow black people
off from work in the event that the uh
the verdict goes different than they
wanted to go i guess because of their
mental anguish uh black people are going
to be so distraught if this man is found
not guilty they need to have some days
off from work i said this guy named
gregory mckelvey by the way how many
white people got the day off when o.j
simpson was uh acquitted from murdering
uh two white people with evidence so so
acute uh he did everything to leave his
business card at the crime scene how
many white people called in sick that
day i mean it's insulting the way
they've played the right pro days off so
i don't know about all that if anybody
gets a day off i think we should all get
a day off no matter what color we are
listen to joy reid i got to show you
this she wants this kid locked up more
than anybody larry listen to what she
said about his testimony
to the car written house trial
it reminded a lot of people of something
the brett kavanaugh hearings in which
brett kavanaugh cried his way through
the hearings in america there's a thing
about both white vigilantism
and white tears
particularly
male white tears
well i didn't know tears had a sex or a
gender did you larry
jesse consider the source joy reid is a
woman who wrote in her blog how much she
disliked homosexuals that she wasn't
going to see the movie broke back
mountain because she doesn't want to see
men kissing denied that she wrote this
claimed she was hacked nbc did a
investigation forensic investigation
found out she wasn't hacked and then she
said she doesn't really realize that she
was writing these things and i apologize
i mean consider the source this is a
race card player there's one million of
them on cnb on msnb hee-haw and she's
one of a bunch of them that's what they
do that's how they roll it's pathetic
racism has never been a less significant
factor in american life after obama got
elected with a higher percentage of the
white vote by the way than uh
than john kerry did four years earlier i
kind of thought this was done but
they're pulling out the race card
because donald trump got 12
of the black vote that's a 50 increase
over what he got in 2016 and they are
scared to death so they're doubling down
on stuff like critical race theory and
reparations it's pathetic
well i wanted to show us a lot of
footage of aoc crying at the border and
barack obama getting choked up and
i think joe biden's white and we have
footage of him crying too so we're not
going to show you guys a bunch of
footage of people crying a lot of white
tears black tears hispanic tears doesn't
matter people cry we get emotional right
larry even larry elder cries
i'm sure
and don't
and jesse don't forget uh uh apparently
uh conley harris's aides have accused uh
joe biden way forward of being a racist
because he apparently he's favoring pete
buda judge over her so the race card is
flying at the west wing of the white
house as well that's right it's the only
card they have left to play larry elder
thank you for coming on hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else